and the dinosaurs inside the Smithsonian
National Museum of Natural History have
been in hiding for nearly five years
while the dinosaur Hall is renovated but
now those fossils are coming out of
storage before the exhibit is reopened
in Washington later this year first on
network television chip read is that the
exhibit to give us a sneak peek of the
renovated space while construction is
still underway chip you can tell I'm
excited about this story good morning
aren't we all
absolutely well that fearsome creature
behind me is one of the most complete
t-rex a--'s in the world and this is the
first time it's ever been completely put
together and put on display it is the
centerpiece here but this exhibit this
massive exhibit is about a lot more than
t-rex meet the nation's t-rex one of the
most complete t-rex is in the world it's
almost entirely real fossils not plaster
like the one it's replacing and instead
of standing like it's posing for a
selfie this one is chomping on an
unfortunate triceratops experts are
painstakingly rebuilding the creatures
piece by piece using the latest
knowledge to make them look more real
Matthew Carano is the museum's curator
of dinosauria they look realer I think
when you portray them doing real things
so like eating another diamond yeah like
eating or sleeping or you know all the
different things animals do not just
posing for a picture I think even though
most of our dinosaurs were real last
time they just looked kind of dusty and
old and static most
if this is what you envision when you
think of a t-rex you might not be that
far off when you watch Jurassic Park and
you see the Tyrannosaurus Rex real fake
they did a pretty good job they did it
probably isn't an animal that roared but
movies need things that are loud so
that's fine Carano knew he wanted to be
a dinosaur scientist when he was in the
second grade but his obsession goes way
beyond the main attraction a lot of kids
have an obsession or at least a
fascination with the Tyrannosaurus Rex
do you I am you know kind of over t-rex
personally it's you know it's our most
famous that's a movie star
it's a movie star doesn't need my help
and it's not just about dinosaurs you'll
also see creatures ranging from the
mastodon to the swalot corax a
prehistoric shark and fins
siobhan stars oversees the project and
it's dozens of experts when you tell
people you've got to come to this
exhibit when it opens what do you tell
them I tell them that it's unique it's
one-of-a-kind they will never find
another fossil haul like and it's not
just about dinosaurs like the t-rex
exactly for Matthew Carano his inner
child has played a central role when
you're deciding how to portray a
dinosaur is that the ten-year-old in you
or the you of today who's deciding what
to do well it's the ten-year-old in me
getting permission from the scientist to
show something so it's got to be real
it's got to be real what do you want a
ten-year-old kid or an 80 year old
person to think and feel when they leave
this exhibit next year I want them to
come in and sort of have their minds
blown just by what's in front of them
you think they will be I'm sure they
will be so get ready to have your minds
blown I mean look at that tail you do
not want this dinosaur wagging its tail
but you are going to have to hold your
horses or in this case hold your
dinosaurs because this exhibit doesn't
open until June 8 yeah that's so nice we
got a little sneak peek thank you very
much Jeffrey
nothing is going to triceratop that
piece
dynomite